anything my outfit displays that i know
a lot more about vagina
than most i know but go ahead i don't
know much about the vagina i'll be
honest with you continue with your
i have no i would i had nowhere to go
try your best when i was doing this i
was like
what else are you gonna say what else
you find something bobby right something
right now this is all
so i have nothing but i'm gonna say this
okay i don't even know much about my own
deck
really yeah i know it's there i know it
works
all the functions are there it's like
you know a fountain machine
at at mcdonald's or whatever you know
you're like i can get stuff out of it
yeah diet coke works
seven eleven seven up works you know
what i mean you mean i can press that
little thing to get water
you know what i mean so it's great it's
free yeah yeah yeah right everything
kind of works
right do you know what the vas deferens
is no she said
what is a badge drunk no that's
different what's the bachelor's
demo what is it to guess yes what are
badges references
a vast deference a vast difference fast
difference
yes a vast difference is let's spell it
out for us first vas
d a f f
r e n c e
hello you had reference episodes to be a
new segment on the pod where
where bobby tells what he thinks a body
part is
yes you can tell us what the vast
reference that's the difference right
er wait would you like the origin
the difference is there's different
differential layers right and microcosms
and organisms whoa that layer within
each other that works in a world in
which
everything kind of co habitates and then
it does transport something what is that
it transports fluids
what color is that and the fluid is in a
yellowish white
white and what's it called what's the
layman's term what [ __ ] juice
but for a penis
yeah they got their events yeah thank
you
did i get the spelling bee by the way
this is the turtle that your nuts look
like
i mean girl yeah tell me how close
delilah can you tell us
virtually identical on a scale to never
ending story turtle
that's virtually identical babe it even
has eyes
okay so that that's what is it now what
is a desk for that friend
you said it is it's a highway for your
spermies yeah oh
i have it yeah you don't have it oh i
thought i it was for you
no it's a male part well it is for us
eventually but
if you want to get pregnant so what
you're saying to me is that like
if i slice open my penis god willing you
know it never happens
it's not in your penis it's outside of
it no
it's it's in your pocket it's in
you legit have your dad's vest
definitely you do you have his voice oh
you do
oh i do right so the test restaurant is
in the um it's in the it's in this death
reference is in the [ __ ] sacks teach
me
go ahead where is it it's in the sacks
it's
it's like between the the sack and
and it goes into the urethra
inside then yeah yeah it's down on the
outside it's not on the outside
is that for sure yeah for sure yeah yeah
yep and it's in here
right in your peen it's in my peen that
connects all the stuff
well just you know it it's the it's the
highway of life it's the highway alive
yeah okay what does it look like right
there it's it's right next to the
scrotum mm-hmm
it's the little line the cord and it
goes all the way up
yeah it's on your it's you can probably
feel basically your balls is where you
you you store your sperm
and it has to travel from your balls
into your your shaft
and that's just the 405 freeway ah
it's a four yeah that's i like it when
it's explained in freeways see
now you know a little bit more about
your peens yeah it's not la cienega
i mean probably you know the shawshank
redemption what's that highway the sauce
and cut off
did you like that movie shawshank
redemption yeah i like to say it
shawshank redemption i think i mean
anything morgan freeman
narrates is great yeah he's great he
could narrate a rape and it would be
fantastic have you
have you seen the show it wouldn't be as
brutal it wouldn't be as brutal
that she was walking down the street
probably shouldn't have won
the man approached with an intent
gate a terrible morgan freeman
depression yeah
it's like a drunk it's like a
do an drug hey guys i'm going to take a
really quick break to share this
dope ass product with you yeah
man crates guys yeah man crates is the
perfect gift for the
for for for the for men and for real men
guys like bert harry kreischer right
sometimes bert harry could fatty
fatty guy oh that guy yeah